one of the issues that elected officials
pay lip service to is nuclear
proliferation and the idea is they all
pretend to want to reduce the number of
nuclear weapons that are out there and
prevent the use of nuclear weapons all
of that stuff I'm sure you've been
hearing it for as long as you've been
paying attention to politics but it's
not super straightforward it's not just
as straightforward as fewer weapons for
all because some countries including the
United States already have a ton of
nukes some other countries also have a
lot of nukes many countries have no
nukes whatsoever so anytime that the
United States takes a position on nukes
you have to understand the context and
you have to know the geopolitics to
really get it so this gets us to Friday
and on Friday Donald Trump's Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo announced that the
United States is going to suspend the
intermediate-range nuclear forces treaty
this is a deal between the United States
and of course Russia from 1987 which was
signed by Reagan and Gorbachev it
eliminated a ton of land-based ballistic
and cruise missiles and their launches
their launchers rather with particular
ranges and the underpinnings of this
entire elimination of the treaty are
really Orwellian in nature if you just
casually heard about this you would
think oh there's a deal limiting the
weapons that Russia can produce so if we
suspend the deal now Russia is free to
produce more weapons as would be the
United States what the Trump
administration says is that Russia has
been ignoring the deal anyway for a long
time so that they're going to get tough
on Russia by suspending the deal so that
the United States can also now produce
more of these weapons to be big and
tough against Russia like Trump wants to
be seen as being big deal right we're
not going to let Russia win on this one
so we're going to suspend the deal and
now Russia has a hundred and eighty days
to return to compliance or the deal goes
entirely dead here are all the things
that you have to understand about this
because it's way more complex
and insidious first of all remember who
has nukes right we're putting up on the
screen a list of nuclear warheads by
country and you'll see that both Russia
and the United States have more than six
thousand each France has 300 and China
has 260 the UK has 215 Pakistan India
Montenegro North Korea Israel have a you
know range of numbers based on estimates
so as you can see the United States and
Russia already have way more nukes than
would ever be needed to blow the world
up many many times over so this isn't
literally about Oh Russia builds a
little capacity so we need to get out of
the deal so that we can build a little
more capacity because neither Russia nor
the United States need any more capacity
this is optics it's the possibility of
using this for other purposes what might
those other purposes be of suspending
this deal well the United States has
already said they'd be open to
negotiations on this they didn't say
with who except we know that it's a deal
with Russia only so that's the only
other party that the United States would
be negotiating with on this so this
could create a pretext for a much bigger
negotiation with Russia about all sorts
of stuff that would again be an
opportunity for Trump to concede who
knows what to Vladimir Putin so then
that gets us to evaluating the process
here is it logical if what we really
want is lush Russia to simply comply
with the agreement would we go directly
to suspending the deal no much more
logical would be before you say we're
suspending the deal you would threaten
to increase sanctions on Russia then you
would increase sanctions on Russia then
you would threaten to drop the treaty
then you would actually announce that
you're starting the 180 day period to
end the treaty but instead we've seen
the Trump administration simply say we
are going to drop the deal
we are also by the way have they been
dropping sanctions on Russia as well now
they'll tell you of course Oh in some
particular cases we added some new
sanctions but those pale compared to the
sanctions that have been dropped so then
we have to
really question the goal here because
there is no downside for Russia if the
United States backs out of the treaty
yes we can also now start to build more
of these mid-range weapons but who cares
we both already have thousands of nukes
and once you game this out fully
considering that we're skipping
sanctions the possible outcomes are this
just means both sides keep scaling up
making nuclear war more likely
mathematically or Putin and Trump meet
to quote negotiate which is never good
for us since Trump is such a disastrous
negotiator and in any case it's all
upside for Russia
it's absolutely pathetic and a lot of
people are completely missing the boat
on this one viewers and listeners of the
David Pakman show with the dog or cat at
home you should check out one of our new
sponsors called pet box which is a
subscription box that sends you premium
treats and toys for your dog or cat
every month you can get 50% off your
first box when you click the link under
this video and use the coupon code
Pakman all you have to do is tell them
what kind of pet you have you tell them
how big your pet is and every month
you'll get a new box filled with a
variety of the latest and greatest high
quality pet snacks and toys made mostly
by small family-owned businesses it also
makes a really great gift for someone
else in your life who has a pet I just
got the dog box for Nemo the English lab
my dad's dog who my Instagram followers
or maybe already acquainted with got a
bunch of really cool stuff including
pterodactyl treats and a true jerky type
thing you can tell I don't have a dog
also a squeeze toy and the coolest thing
about pet box is that they give 10% of
the proceeds to a nonprofit called
tender loving canines which does really
good things number one they provide
service dogs to people with autism
number two they provide service dogs for
veterans who have PTSD so your pet is
getting an array of fun things to play
with and snack on every month but you're
also contributing to a really good cause
and as I mentioned you can get half
off of that first box when you click the
link underneath this video and use the
coupon code Pakman that's P a que ma n